وفي اخر تفاصيل المشهد بتركيا في اليوم
الرابع من الكارثه ارتفع عدد قتل الزلزال
الى نحو
1700 قتيل وفق نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد
اخطائي الذي قال ان عدد من تم انقاذهم
قارب ثلاثه وسبعين الفا وبينما لا تزال
تركيا تحصي قتلاها ومصابيها تتواصل الهزات
والارتداديه رسلت حتى الان
1400 هزه ارتداديه ومع استمرار عمليات
الانقاذ لليوم الرابع على التوالي صداق
البرلمان التركي على اعلان حاله الطوارئ
في الولايات العشر المنكوبه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان شدد على ان
الاولويه تبقى لايواء المتضررين واوضح في
زياره تفاقديه لمدينه غازي عنتاب جنوبيه
تركيا ان بناء منازل للمتضررين هو اولويه
الدوله
كما ترون فان اعمال رفع الانقاض ما زالت
مستمره فمنذ اللحظه الاولى للزلزال تعمل
كل مؤسسات الدوله بقوه على الارض هدفنا ان
نبني منازل لجميع المواطنين المتضررين في
المحافظات العشر خلال عام بالاضافه الى
تعويضهم عن ممتلكاتهم وذلك عقب منح كل
عائله متضرره مبلغ 10 الاف ليره في
المرحله الاولى املا في تخفيف بعض الامهم